let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 our buddy Caesar from San
Antonio is on the phone and he will
often have questions I like so let's see
Caesar what do you have for us today
hello
yeah Caesar go ahead yeah I have a
question I would ask - um do you think
the US should invest in in stuff like
bullet trains or even the Hyperloop yes
I do and the reason that we don't and
were so embarassingly behind on train
stuff is that we have population centers
in the u.s. which are disproportionately
in some states but when the country
meaning the House and Senate decide how
we are going to spend our money you have
senators and congressmen from parts of
the country with relatively small
populations who get to vote because
they're part of the house they're part
of the Senate so if you are a
congressman in the middle of Iowa and
there's going to be a really fast train
set up to go down the east coast from
Boston to Washington DC and I don't mean
the Acela I mean a genuinely fast train
what's the advantage if you're in Iowa
when you need to go and defend your
re-election to your constituents why
would you support that if if you don't
actually care about anything other than
getting reelected so that's why we don't
have it and I absolutely think we should
be supporting that stuff it's a joke how
far behind we are on untrained
transportation so do you support the
Hyperloop I mean I don't so I don't know
enough about its bigger picture
viability but I love the project and I
think it's fascinating and I would love
to see it made a reality sure I think
also a lot of people the reason why like
the airline industry is kind of worried
because they think that it might put
them out of business
oh absolutely yeah so if you understand
so the perfect example is a Boston to
Philadelphia okay Boston to Philadelphia
driving is it must be what about seven
hours pat six seven hours something like
that you can fly there in like 50 or 60
minutes but of course you've got to get
there
an hour and 15 minutes before your
flight and you've got to get through
security and you've got to get to the
airport so if you live a half hour from
the airport you know it's it starts to
add up if the trains get significantly
faster than cars people will choose to
take the train instead of flying or
driving because it's less of a hassle to
take the train and you don't have to sit
there and drive so both the automobile
industry and the airline industry do not
want fast trains and and in fact the the
coach bus Oh Peter Pan is like a bus
company based here in Massachusetts they
strongly oppose commuter rail that goes
from Springfield to Boston because
that's one of their bread-and-butter
routes and if you can take them more
convenient and roomier train who's gonna
want to take the bus so yeah that's a
big factor Cesar okay all right thank
you for the call Cesar great to hear
from you Cesar in San Antonio our caller
ID system is working that's the good
news so we know when when certain
certain people call